FEMALE SPEAKER: Ladies and
gentlemen, Floyd Abrams.
[CLAPPING]
FLOYD ABRAMS: Thank you.
Thank you all for coming.
The special privilege really to
be here at Google, I want
you to know that I hear about
Google all the time in the
course of the work that I do.
Mostly because when I teach
students at law school, and
when I talk with professors of
First Amendment law, one of
the first things they always
say is, well look, first
amendment's about the
government, and we have things
pretty well under
control there.
The single most important
decision maker in the world
about freedom of speech
is Google.
And Google's rules, and what
Google decides goes on or off,
is center stage very often in
discussions at law schools and
in a variety of places you
wouldn't think so.
The First Amendment, of course,
is, as part of the
Bill of Rights, applies only
to the government.
It's a limitation on the
government, it prevents the
government from interfering in
a variety of ways, freedom of
speech, freedom of press,
freedom of religion, freedom
of assembly, et cetera.
And I'd done a lot of
teaching about it.
And my recent book tries to deal
with a lot of the events
and a lot of the conflict that
have arisen with respect to
the First Amendment, really in
the last 40 and 50 years.
Some of them recur.
And Google's always around
the corner, by the way,
when they do recur.
One chapter in my book deals
with confidential sources of
journalists.
I've been involved in a lot of
battles with the government
and private parties who have
sought to get court orders
requiring journalists
to reveal the
identity of their sources.
Journalists promise, as you
know, confidentiality, try to
keep those promises when they
make them, and they wind up in
court sometimes.
And sometimes they don't.
And that's been one of the big
issues of the last few weeks,
as you've read with respect to
the Associated Press case.
The Department of Justice
in the course of a leak
investigation in which the
department was trying to find
out who in the government
provided certain information
about a terrorist attempt in
Yemen to bring down an
American airplane.
The Associated Press
had received
information about that.
And they behaved in a
particularly responsible way.
They went to the government,
they went to the CIA, they
asked, would it do any real
harm if we published this?
And the answer was, yes.
We're in the middle of doing
what we're doing, someone
could be hurt.
And so they didn't
publish anything.
Until they learned that the
government was about to hold a
press conference the next day
announcing a great success in
preventing the terrorists
from bringing down
this American plane.
AP went to press then, did its
story, and in the meantime, a
leak investigation had begun.
Who told AP about this?
And the basic rules of the game
that the Department of
Justice is supposed to play
by are rules in which
the press goes last.
They're supposed to take
lie detector tests.
They're supposed to
interview people.
They're supposed to do all the
things to try to avoid
conflict with the press until
it's absolutely necessary to
go to the journalists themselves
and either try to
get a court order to require
them to reveal their sources
or somehow work something out,
which would be to help them to
learn their sources.
The only exception to the
obligation of the Department
of Justice in this area, the
only time when they are
allowed not to talk to the
journalists, not to talk to
the AP in this situation, is
if doing so would interfere
with the quote, integrity,
unquote of the
investigation itself.
You know, would blow
the investigation.
Would make it impossible for
them to find out for one
reason or another who leaked
the information.
They did not tell the AP that
they were interested in their
telephone records.
They went to the telephone
company and served a subpoena
on the telephone company,
saying, turn over to us the AP
records of 20 or so telephones
used by over 100 journalists
over a two month period.
And the telephone companies
turned it over.
And that's been the basis of a
great deal of controversy in
the last week really because
this is all very new stuff
that we're talking about.
People, myself included, have
been critical of the
Department of Justice, basically
saying, we can't
imagine a scenario in which
telling the AP that you wanted
their phone records would have
interfered with the integrity
of your investigation, except
for one scenario.
And that is that if you told
them, they would go to court,
which is true.
They didn't go to court because
they didn't know that
anyone was interested in
their phone records.
And it's true that if
they went to court,
months would pass.
Now, that's not a very good
reason, certainly if you think
the First Amendment
is involved.
If you think that journalists
have, or ought to have a
right, as a generality at least,
not to reveal their
confidential sources.
And so the controversy about
that one is basically, did the
Department of Justice play by
the rules in going right to
the phone company instead of
going right to the Associated
Press in this area?
The other one, which is more
relevant maybe to Google, is
this subpoena that was served.
A search warrant that
was served--
and again, we learned this
only three days ago--
on the chief Fox correspondent
in Washington in the course of
another leak investigation.
That one about information about
North Korea and their
atomic capabilities and
facilities and the like.
And in that one, the government
did, and we're not
sure of all the things they've
done, but a lot of things to
try to find out who the source
of that information was.
And not having learned it or
not having learned it with
sufficient clarity, they
took the next step.
They went to a court.
There is a court, a secret
court, as it happens, which
deals with certain types of
highly sensitive national
security related matters.
And they asked for the right to
serve a subpoena, really a
search warrant, on Google.
They said, this journalist who
got this information about
North Korea, himself, is a
potential criminal because he
spoke to someone in the
executive branch of
government, he cajoled him, he
flattered him, he appealed to
his vanity.
All these words are from
the application
for a search warrant.
And he ultimately persuaded
him to provide information
that he wasn't allowed
to provide.
Now most journalists would say,
what the journalist did
was almost a definition
of journalism.
Cajoling and flattering and
appealing to egos of a
potential source.
But in their application for a
search warrant, the government
said, that's a crime, a crime
under the Espionage Act of
releasing information, even
a non-government employee,
releasing certain type of very
sensitive information which
you had no right to release.
That's a position
the government
had never taken before.
That's big news to accuse a
journalist of violating the
Espionage Act for basically
acting like a journalist.
And rightly, in my view, has
been the subject of a great
deal of attention and a great
deal of criticism of the
Department of Justice.
The alternative offered by the
FBI agent, who wrote or signed
onto this affidavit, was, well,
if you didn't violate
the Espionage Act, at the least
you are an aider and
abettor, somebody who worked
with the guy in the executive
branch who provided information
he wasn't allowed
to provide.
And that, too, is something
which the government had never
maintained.
Historically, we've had a
situation where the press and
the governments have often been
in conflict, have too
often been in bed together, but
have worked out a sort of
general modus vivendi and worked
out a general, you do
your thing, we do our thing.
A former Secretary of State
writing to a New York Times
columnist put it this way.
He said, your job is to pry,
mine is to keep secret.
And both sides have generally
understood that to that
extent, at least, there's an
inherent conflict in what the
government wants by way of
secrecy, and what the press
wants in the sense of getting
information that they can
release to the public.
And generally, you know,
they've gotten
along pretty well.
Some people think too well,
at least in the sense that
there's no doubt that Washington
is and has been for
years, you know, a
hot bed of leaks.
The Department of Defense leaks
information when the
Secretary of Defense advocates
cutting back the budget.
You know, where does The New
York Times, where does the
Washington Post, where do the
television stations get
information that the people
are really worried about
cutting out this
weapons system?
It's usually from leaks from
within the Pentagon.
And we read lots of leaks all
the time from security
agencies, from the CIA,
from all over.
Certainly from the
White House.
And that's true in all
administrations.
So what happened here is that
Google became involved as the
entity which received the papers
from the court, saying,
turn over the personal emails
of the journalist.
And it did so.
And that combination of events,
the Associated Press
issue and the Fox News
journalist issue, have been
one of the sort of three tough
events, in terms of the
presidency at least, that
we've seen in the
last week or two.
The others being the Internal
Revenue Service matter and
depending on your view of the
matter, that which has been
coming out about events in
Benghazi, et cetera.
And for those of us in this
area, the government walked
over a line that had been pretty
clear in the past in
accusing in so many words the
Fox journalist of having
committed a criminal act by
asking questions of someone
who, and I'm trying to be fair
now, who wasn't allowed to
answer them.
But that's the way things
have generally been.
In my book, I try to deal with
a lot of different subjects
which in one way or another
affect freedom of speech and
freedom of the press.
And in a class I taught at Yale
Law School last year, we
devoted a few days to the
subject of privacy, personal
privacy, and of defamation,
libel, slander, saying
something about someone else
which is untrue, and for one
reason or another, unprotected
by the law.
We asked a Yale law student to
come as a visitor, a speaker,
a guest, to the class we
taught on this subject.
The reason was that she had been
victimized by a website
which was anonymously run-- but
this all later came out--
by a law student at a different
law school who had
created a website basically by
reading another website in
which students in college were
talking about what law
school to go to.
They all had anonymous names.
But he basically tracked them.
And he tracked attractive
women.
There were pictures in, there
were Facebook-like pictures,
in the law schools
after you enter.
So he would compare what people
were saying while they
were seniors in college about,
I have a choice between this
law school and that law school,
and I've done this and
that, and this is my history,
et cetera, with the pictures
that he saw in the books of
the great law school.
And he would be able to
find some women--
he didn't know any of them--
to find some women who he could
be sure were the same
people that were talking in
college, who went to this and
that law school.
And he put their picture in, and
he would make up stories
about them, terrible stories,
mostly sexual but
not limited to that.
But just saying awful
things about them.
And saying that, of course,
without anonymity, life being
as it is in this age.
Well a few of the women were
law students at Yale.
They got pro bono assistance
from some lawyers.
They went to court.
They got a court order requiring
disclosure of the
anonymous speaker, which
one can get in certain
circumstances, but
is not the rule.
And we had her in class to talk
about her experience.
And I think all of
us were really
surprised on a few levels.
One, there were three of
us who were teaching.
We're each about 10 years apart
in age, and then you
take another 20 years off
between the youngest person
and the student.
And all of us that were teaching
were sort of struck
by the fact that we seemed
angrier than
anyone in the class.
The students said, oh,
we know that website.
No one believes anything
on that website anyway.
And she said, the victim, the
person we were especially, not
just sorry for her, but felt
had been terribly abused,
said, well maybe I shouldn't
have sued.
Maybe it wasn't a good idea.
You know that just got
more publicity.
But it's all about page
one of My Google.
Said that, you know, someone
looks me up for a date,
someone likes me up for a
job, and there are these
charges on page one.
If it only weren't page
one, she said.
And so she said, I
needed an answer.
I needed a court to say, in
effect, it's all untrue.
And she's gotten that.
But it's an example, I think,
of how, with new technology
and the like, we have new legal
problems and new first
amendment-like problems.
Is anonymity protected
on websites?
Can the government, can a court,
which is part of the
government, can a court
issue an order?
Should a court issue an order?
When should a court issue an
order requiring the anonymity
to be breached?
I go back a long way
in this area.
And one of the first cases I
worked on, which is discussed
in this book, was all the
way back in 1971,.
And it was the Pentagon Papers
case, in which the US
government went to court to try
to get an order stopping
the New York Times from
publishing information it had
received about a secret study
that the Defense Department
had prepared about how we got
into the war in Vietnam.
The Secretary of Defense, Robert
McNamara, had asked for
a study to be done answering
the question, why
were we in the war?
There were people that thought
maybe he should have read that
before we got into the war.
But in any event, he asked
that it be prepared.
The Defense Department brought
in a bunch of scholars and
other people to write it.
It was just sort of a
devastating document.
It was over 20 volumes.
Devastating because it really
did show that starting way
back in the mid '40s, after the
end of World War II and
thereafter, that American
presence in Vietnam grew and
grew, and that the public was
not accurately told what our
involvement was, why we were
there, what we were doing, et
cetera, et cetera.
In any event, one of
the authors decided
that the war was wrong.
He thought it was a war crime.
And he made available to the New
York Times almost all the
volumes that had been prepared
of what became known as the
Pentagon Papers.
And the Times started writing
articles about it, and the
government under President Nixon
went to court seeking a
court order requiring the Times
to stop publishing this
material, which was labeled
top secret, which is the
highest level of secrecy in the
government, even though
not everything called top
secret really is.
But that's another story.
But in any event, that's the
highest level in theory of the
classification.
And we won the case.
And it was a great victory.
It would have been an
even greater defeat.
The country really would be
different if we lost the case.
But in any event,
we won the case.
And it was a moment at the end
of the case that I often look
back on, particularly with
respect to WikiLeaks and their
behavior, of course,
much more recently.
When the case was over in the
lower court, in the federal
district court, the federal
judge ruled in our favor.
And he called me into his
office, his chambers, and he
called a senior partner of
mine inti his chambers.
And he said something
like this.
He said, you know, you've won
the case, at least with me.
The Times can publish
what it wants.
Now I want to talk to you
as a private citizen.
I'm not a judge anymore.
I'm finished with the case.
There is some material in
there, in particular a
particular contingency plan for
what was called SEATO, the
Southeast Asia Treaty
Organization, the US and
various Asian countries in
alliance together, which I
really think the Times
shouldn't print.
And it's this and
this and this.
And I really wish-- and he
used the word "wish"--
I really wish you'd tell them
that that's what I think.
I'm not entering an order.
Again, I'm not a
judge anymore.
I'm just telling you
what I think.
And we said we would
tell them.
And we did.
They had already decided not to
publish a lot of material
from that contingency plan.
They took another look.
They decided not to publish
some more of it, and to
publish some of what the judge
had identified because the
Times didn't think that it
threatened national security.
And I've always thought, that's
the way the system's
supposed to work.
Basically, the judge is giving
very, very wide birth to the
press, except in the most
extraordinary circumstance
where publication is very likely
to really harm national
security in a very real way and
imminently and as a result
of publication, not as a result
of anything else.
And I thought, you know,
he behaved--
and I still think--
he behaved really well in ruling
in our favor at the
same time he had
these concerns.
And I thought the Times
behaved well in taking
seriously what he said about
how he thought that this
particular material could do,
might do, some harm to
national security.
I contrast that with the
WikiLeaks situation, where
WikiLeaks in my view has been
reckless in its decision
making about what documents to
release and what documents not
to release.
One example, WikiLeaks received
apparently from this
Private Manning who's now on
trial approximately 91,000
military reports of American
serviceman in Afghanistan.
WikiLeaks, at that time,
had already been under
considerable criticism for the
release of other information
of a variety of sorts and
withheld at least immediately
some thousands of them,
at least while they
read through them.
But they released to the public
77,000 of the 91,000.
And the journalists asked Mr.
Assange at a press conference,
the head of WikiLeaks, have
you guys read the 77,000
reports that you're releasing?
And he said, well we've read
about 2,000 of them.
The journalists said, how
can you release them?
And the answer was, we don't
have any reason to think that
they would harm national
security.
Now my reaction to that is first
of all, this is not the
stuff of journalism we're
talking about.
Journalists don't hand out
documents, they read them and
report on them.
But that's not enough of an
answer because the First
Amendment doesn't protect
just journalists.
If Julian Assange is what I
think of him as being, as sort
of a political activist, that
doesn't mean he's not entitled
to First Amendment protection.
He's just not the press
if I'm right.
But whether he's the press, or
not, if he ever were charged,
if he came to the US and were
charged, he would have some
serious First Amendment
defenses, at least if the
documents did not do significant
harm or did not
significantly threaten national
security in one way
or another.
That said, there's a difference
between what I
would call press responsibility
and what the
First Amendment protects.
The First Amendment doesn't
require responsibility.
It doesn't require judges to
pass on what is responsible
journalism, or not.
And it doesn't require judges
to agree, or not agree, with
publication or release of
document-like decisions.
What it does do is to say, the
government's got to keep its
hands off, except in really
extraordinary circumstances.
And that's especially true
when you're talking about
people who aren't in
the government.
People who are in the government
have special
obligations.
And the Supreme Court has indeed
gone so far as to say
that even if there were no
contract, as there is, between
the CIA, say, and employees,
agents, of the CIA, and they
make them all sign a contract
promising not to disclose
things that they have
learned, et cetera.
But even if that were not so,
the Supreme Court had said, we
would assume--
we would treat it as if there
were a contract because the
relationship, at least of the
CIA to the government, and the
role of the CIA, is such that
it is that important to have
that level of secrecy.
So in all these areas, we see
the First Amendment is a
barrier, a great
barrier, hardly
ever a complete barrier.
I mean the courts have always
left, and Congress has always
left, some sort of out in
situations of great national
peril or in other areas of law,
libel law, privacy law,
and the like.
While those bodies of law we
lean over very strongly in the
direction of the press or of
speakers, of revealers, of
talkers and the like, while
all that is true, we still
have libel law in America.
People still sue.
Not so often, not as often as in
other democratic countries.
I mean, we provide so much
protection for free speech
that a lot of the lawsuits which
are commonplace in other
democratic countries simply
don't happen here.
I mean, in England, the Prime
Minister brings libel suits.
The Queen brings libel suits
when people say bad things
that they make up.
I know you'll be shocked
to hear that the press
occasionally makes up stuff.
Not the people that I represent,
but others.
But what's interesting to me
about that is that it leads to
sort of a different culture.
The fact that it's so hard to
win a libel suit for a public
official in America puts us in
a situation where when a
candidate for office, say, is
accused of some sort of
misconduct, the press doesn't
go around and say, are you
suing for libel?
Or how can you let
that be said?
Why don't you sue?
In England, the candidate would
be expected to sue.
In England, it would be assumed
if he didn't sue, it
must be true.
And that was just an unintended
consequence of the
difference in libel law that we
have in the two countries.
One of the greatest First
Amendment contributions that
our Supreme Court has given us
is really to move us away from
English law, notwithstanding
that our law comes initially,
certainly, from English law.
I mean, they are the mother
country in terms of American
law in most areas and in most
constitutional areas.
But time and again, but starting
some years back, the
Supreme Court has said, the
purpose of the Bill of Rights,
the purpose of the First
Amendment, was to give
Americans far more protection
against the government than
exists anywhere else in the
world, including England.
And so you have situations
where, let's say, a trial is
going on, a highly publicized
trial, Jody Arias.
Anything you can see on
television or read about on a
regular basis.
In England, the press is allowed
to report fairly and
accurately about what
happens in court.
They're not allowed to report
on a confession until it's
introduced in court.
They're not allowed to report
about a prior criminal record
of a defendant unless
and until it is
introduced in court.
Here, what the press learns,
the press can publish.
Here, if the press learns that
some defendant in some case
has confessed, it's published.
Well how do we deal with it?
How do we assure a defendant
a fair trial?
We do a lot of more things than
they do over there, in
part because we have to,
but in part, for
other historical reasons.
We do a lot more things
to assure a
defendant a fair trial.
That's one of the reasons
our trials take so long.
That's one of the reasons you
sometimes see people going
free who may have done terrible
things but because
the government has failed to
meet some technical sounding.
But nonetheless, significant
element of proof.
And all that really began as far
back as 1941, in which the
Supreme Court had a case in
which there had been a strike.
And this was right on the verge
of World War II, the
American World War
II, beginning.
It was a big strike of the
Teamsters, the people who work
loading and unloading on boats
and ships, and the like, in
California.
There was a court order for
them to go back to work.
The union defied the order.
The head of the union was held
in contempt of court.
And he was up for sentencing
in front of the judge.
And the Los Angeles Times had an
editorial saying, send him
to the jute mill.
I'm not even sure what jute
means, but it's not a good
place to be sent.
He said, the LA Times said in
the clearest terms, you ought
to be as severe as
you possibly can.
This guy is interfering with
national defense, and you
really ought to crack
down on him.
In England, then and now, that's
a contempt of court.
The editor would go to jail in
England today for saying that
on the ground that interferes
with the processes of justice.
When I was in college,
I agreed with that.
I wrote a whole thesis arguing
that we ought to move towards
the English system because
I thought it
made a sort of sense.
I have since come to different
views after I started
practicing law and after
I started meeting some
journalists and after I started
realizing some of the
benefits, and hopefully
understanding, at least, the
potential harm, of some
of the benefits of
living in a freer system.
Basically, what our Supreme
Court said in that case in a
decision by purest chance,
decided the day after Pearl
Harbor, the court said something
like what I almost
quoted to you a few
minutes ago.
Nothing is clearer about the
drafting of the American Bill
of Rights in the US
Constitution, the first 10
amendments, that it was designed
to provide American
citizens with far more
protection in all these areas
than exist elsewhere
in the world,
particularly in England.
And unless publication, it
will be such a clear and
present danger to the
administration of justice.
Unless a judge simply can't
function for one reason or
another, press is free to say
what they want, free to
criticize the judge, free to
lobby the judge, free to write
editorials, basically saying,
you know, you better send this
guy away as long as possible.
Judges, Justice Hugo Black
wrote, are supposed to be
hardy in nature.
They're supposed to be strong.
And we will not allow, he
wrote, free speech to be
interfered with because of the
possibility that a judge will
be weak-kneed, timid, unwilling
to follow the law
because he or she is
being criticized.
Let me offer you a final example
of one of the very
controversial subjects talked
about in my book.
And it's a subject where my
views are not very popular
with most of my friends, most of
the people with whom I tend
to agree politically
and the like.
That's the case you've heard
about called the Citizens
United case.
It was a decision of the Supreme
Court four or five
years ago now, which said that
it was unconstitutional that
it violated the First Amendment
for Congress to pass
a law saying that if any
corporate money was spent for
or against the election of a
candidate within 60 days of an
election, and the money was
spent to endorse or to
denounce the candidate,
that that was a crime.
Purpose of the law was to try
to deal with the problem of
money in politics.
Too much money, too few people,
too much power for
those people, and the like.
Serious stuff.
But raised a very significant
First Amendment issues.
The conservative group called
Citizens United, which was
partially funded by
corporate grants--
mostly, not actually,
but partly--
did a movie, a documentary.
They said that then Senator
Hillary Clinton--
this was 2008--
then Senator Clinton was the
leading candidate for the
Democratic nomination.
Of course, Senator Obama
was nominated.
But at that time, it looked
as if Hillary
Clinton would be nominated.
It was an hour and a
half program, film.
And it was all attack from
beginning to end.
It was a screed, a primal
scream, not to
elect her as president.
And it was the desire of
this group to have
it on pay per view.
Because it was within
60 days--
or 30 days of a primary, which
was another key point in the
statute-- within 30 days of
a primary, 30 days of a
political convention, or 60
days of the election, that
would not be allowed on
television, on cable, or on
satellite under the statute.
The question was, was
that constitutional?
The Supreme Court divided
five to four.
The five, it's the court's
most conservative members
wrote an opinion--
I was one of the two lawyers
in that case who are on the
side of Citizens United--
wrote an opinion saying,
the statute
violates the First Amendment.
We're talking about speech
about an election.
Were talking about who to
vote for for president.
There is nothing more important
that we have free
speech about, and it doesn't
matter that the money comes
from a corporation.
The court said, we've had case
after case involving
corporations, mostly ones that
own newspapers, broadcasters,
and the like.
But not just those who've
engaged in speech.
We've said it was protected.
And that can't be
overcome here.
Well it remains an extremely
unpopular opinion.
President Obama denounced it
in his State of the Union
message the January after it
came out and has said more
recently that he's considering
supporting a constitutional
amendment to reverse it.
The New York Times, Washington
Post, most of the leading
newspapers--
in fact, I would say, really
almost all of them other than
ones that are decidedly
conservative, like the Wall
Street Journal, say, or a
National Review as a magazine.
But the great balance of press
commentary has been extremely
hostile to the opinion that
basically on the ground, and a
perfectly understandable one,
that it allows corporations
perhaps to have too much power,
spend too much money,
have too much influence on what
happens in the country.
My view is that that
is a danger.
I don't think we ought
to deal with that
danger by limiting speech.
If we want to pass laws designed
to have a more
egalitarian, a more equal,
society, I think we can do it.
Congress is of no mind
to do it now.
But I'm just saying, if they
wanted to do it, if they
wanted to raise taxes on
corporations, if they wanted
to have stronger antitrust laws,
if they wanted to do
economic things to deal with an
economic problem, my view
is, that's one thing.
You could like them or not like
them as ideas, but they
have nothing to do with
the First Amendment.
That Congress is free
to do those things.
The states are free to
do those things.
We don't even have to
have corporations.
Nothing in the Constitution
requiring the existence of
corporations.
States allow corporations
to exist.
But my view is that when you're
talking about speech,
about elections, in particular,
when you're
talking about political speech,
when you're talking
about who to vote for, that
that's the area in which
Congress ought to have the least
power, not the most.
And that Congress ought to be
obliged to stay away from
areas such as this and from
passing statutes such as this.
That's a very controversial
position, but I did want to
set it forth.
I wind up the book like this.
I say, is it too much to ask
that people who say they care
about the First Amendment,
everybody, that is, really
mean it when they say that
everybody ought to have a free
say about what they think?
Do we really mean it when one of
the great old Supreme Court
opinions, it says the First
Amendment means we protect the
speech that we hate.
And the question that I ask
throughout this book is, do we
really mean that?
Or are we really in almost the
same situation with the First
Amendment as we are with
everything else in our society?
You know, left ones,
left speech,
right ones, right speech.
Everybody is willing to cut into
the speech of the others.
And I sort of appeal to the
reader to support First
Amendment freedoms
across the board.
To support the ability to
people, basically, not just to
have freedom of thought, but the
freedom of expression in
the ways that the
First Amendment
most obviously protects.
Freedom of speech, freedom
of the press, broadly
interpreted, and only limited
in very, very rare
circumstance.
So that's what the
book is about.
I'm glad to appear
before you today.
I'll be glad to take any
questions or comments.
[CLAPPING]
FLOYD ABRAMS: I should say
first, you have to agree with
me, though.
[LAUGHTER]
FLOYD ABRAMS: Right?
AUDIENCE: So I actually wanted
to ask you sort of a follow up
question about the
Yale law student.
FLOYD ABRAMS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's really less a
First Amendment question than
sort of just your views about
the privacy issue involved.
Because I think sometimes these
issues get a little
muddled in people's minds.
So if we sort of walk the cat
back a little bit there and we
just take the situation where
the student's in college and
makes statements on some
website, although with a
anonymous name about, you know,
I'd rather go to Yale
than Harvard because I think
Harvard Law School stinks and
Yale's much better, right?
And then ultimately, she winds
up getting into Harvard
instead of Yale.
And some, whether it's the
person on that website or
somebody else, tracks down
this public, although
anonymous, statement, and also
through non-criminal means,
determines that this person is
now a student at Harvard and
puts the two of those together
and publishes that
information.
I mean I don't think
there's a privacy
expectation there, right?
Because they put all that
information out there.
But I'm just curious as to
whether you agree, or not.
FLOYD ABRAMS: No, I agree.
But there is a libel one if they
make up stuff about her.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, right.
FLOYD ABRAMS: Which
is what they did.
No, but on a privacy basis,
I agree with you.
And look, one of the realities
these days, these years, and
well into the future so far as
we can see, is that people are
saying so much about themselves
online and
otherwise that willingly or not,
or thoughtfully or not,
they're giving up.
They're choosing to give up,
in a sense, their privacy.
I mean if you write something
down and send it out and don't
find some effective way of
concealing who you are, it's
your problem.
AUDIENCE: And if I could just
ask one follow up question on
a different subject about the
question of leaks by the
government.
FLOYD ABRAMS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you know, my sense
is that you agree that
it can't be stopped
at this point.
It's essentially become a policy
tool for whichever
administration is in power in
order to push the political
debate one way or the other,
or influence Congress, or
influence the public.
But I wonder--
I'll speak for myself--
I feel like there's a really
corrosive effect there.
And the best example I can think
of is the lead up to the
Iraq War, where it turned out
that the administration was
feeding the New York Times
information and then quoting
the information that it had been
fed on the Sunday talk
shows in order to say, well
look, it was published in the
New York Times.
This was true.
And so it seems like it's
one thing to say,
OK, we're going to--
any government, doesn't matter
whether it's Democratic or
Republican, it's one thing to
say we're going to leak
because we want to push public
policy one way or another.
But it's something else then
to implicate the newspapers
directly as a sort of a
policy making tool.
And I just wonder what
you think about that.
FLOYD ABRAMS: I agree.
And as you said by way of
introduction, there's not a
legal comment, and your question
wasn't about the law.
The Iraqi situation is an
interesting one in some ways.
I believe that the scientists
who were quoted in those New
York Times articles believed
what they were saying.
I also think I know that the
reporter who I represented who
wrote those articles believed
but she was saying.
But the government certainly, we
know now, was engaged in a
campaign to gather public
support for the war that
included in the information
they provided were false
statements.
Not just proved to be false,
but known to be false.
And that is unacceptable
behavior.
And your example couldn't
be more on point.
They not only leaked the
information, then when it was
published they said, the New
York Times said, as if they
had nothing to do with
the information
getting to the Times.
And that sort of cynicism
it sounds like
the stuff of novels.
But that's what happened.
And what can you say other
than it's worthy of
condemnation.
We hope it doesn't happen, or
we hope if it does happen,
it's exposed.
Anyone else?
Yes.
Did I see a hand or I see--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
FLOYD ABRAMS: Hello.
AUDIENCE: So from what I know,
the First Amendment protects
citizens against what citizens
say from interference by the
government.
And I was wondering it still
allows interference by private
individuals and corporations?
So what do you think--
should something change there?
Should this be allowed or should
it become more strong
in favor of protecting?
Because it's not only the
government that can threaten
your speech.
Increasingly where you write
your comments, where you
create speech, is owned
not by the government.
It's like a platform
that is online.
Or like where you're employed,
the employer has some power
over what you can say, and
you can't control that.
Should the government have per
se a positive obligation to
ensure that the citizens have
freedom of expression up to a
point and ensuring that other
entities do not interfere with
these rights?
FLOYD ABRAMS: That's a
very, very serious
and powerful question.
First, simply as a legal matter,
the answer is easier
than the policy question
that you're asking.
As a legal matter, the Bill of
Rights applies only to the
government.
It's even phrased, you know,
Congress shall make no law
abridging the freedom of
speech or of the press.
Congress has been expanded to
mean the President and the
states and the courts,
et cetera.
But it's all government
entities.
But your question's a
lot better and more
interesting than that.
There are countries that do
protect far more than we do.
A private speech against
private institutions,
corporations, employers.
We are basically a laissez faire
country in general in
that respect.
You know, people can say what
they want, and other people
can hold them accountable, which
is to say they can get
fired for saying it.
They can be punished, so long
as it's not the government
doing it, for saying it.
And the question of whether,
putting aside the
Constitution, whether we think
it's a good idea to, in
effect, import the government
into that situation by saying
to the government, why don't
you do something to ensure
that private speech shall not
be so subject to control or
sanctions or the like by large,
powerful, private
institutions?
My reaction is that I don't
think we should go in that
direction in part because I
don't trust the government to
be in effect the decision maker
or even to interfere for
the good purpose of protecting
more speech.
But it is a very real issue.
And for a lot of people in a lot
of situations, it's much
more real than any of the fights
that I've been talking
about between the government
and the people or the
government and the press,
and the like.
One of my concerns
is that there has
been a tendency abroad--
one of the things I think we've
learned as a country--
is that there really is a domino
effect, to use a bad
phrase from a different
generation, when you sort of
put the government into the role
of helper, assurer, of
free speech rights is that
there's a great tendency, and
there has been a great tendency
in abroad, to wind up
with the government
in the news room.
And the government as decision
maker, not just about keeping
people from keeping other people
from speaking, but in
other situations.
But that's just a very
short answer
to a very hard question.
This is not a promise, and
there's no reason for you to
care about what I'm about to
say, but I do owe the Yale
University Press
one more book.
And that is something that I've
thought of writing about.
Yes.
Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: As technology
continues to develop, we're
finding more and more
ways to communicate.
We had landline phones and wire
tap regulations, cell
phones, cordless phones, and now
electronic communications,
text, texting, online email.
And these are all mechanisms
of person to person
communication.
Do you think that technology is
fundamentally changing the
way that we view and are
given these rights?
And do you think that's the
right thing to happen?
FLOYD ABRAMS: I don't have any
doubt that technology is
changing the way we exercise
the rights, and therefore,
changing our ability to engage
in those rights.
Also as technology changes the
issues, we'll change, although
have the same base sort of
characteristics and arguments
about them, about what the
role of government is in
assuring fairness, as per
the last question.
Net neutrality comes up.
I mean, other ideas are voiced
and placed on the public
agenda to try to deal with the
reality of new technology.
I mean, one way it comes up is
simply one where the issue
then becomes, is there any more
need for this regulation
or that regulation at all since
there's so much speech
in this area?
I did a case for Time Warner
Cable, which is on awaiting a
decision now, about whether it
is still constitutional under
the First Amendment for Congress
to have required
cable companies to carry
networks, basically, that they
don't want to carry.
And one of the arguments we made
is, look, there's so much
speech from so many sources
now, you've
got to let them go.
And if not now, later.
So the changing forms of
technology affects everything.
It affects privacy, we were
talking about earlier.
It is even leading to some very
interesting cases in the
libel area, for example.
One judge wrote an opinion
basically saying, online
speech by its nature is not
taken as literally as the
speech in my book, you know,
with a hard cover on it and
everything.
People don't mean it.
It's more casual.
It's not take to mean the
ultimate meanings of what one
might view it if it appeared
in a different medium of
communication.
And I don't have any doubt that
we're going to need a lot
more decisions and a lot more
legal decisions as the
on-the-ground reality changes.
And of course the laws
always behind.
Technology's way ahead of
anything that the law can
handle, or predict or be
ready to deal with.
And by the time cases come up
to the court, sometimes the
technology has already changed
to such an extent that the
issue isn't even that
relevant anymore.
But the thrust of your question
I agree with.
And we're going to--
the pace of the change of
technology in this country is
so great that it is very hard
for the law to keep pace with
it in terms of even trying to
deal with it, and in a society
where, as I suggested earlier,
that Congress can't agree on
almost anything anyway.
It means we'll be sort of even
more laissez faire, as it
were, for better or worse.
There will be probably less
regulation for better or worse
because no one's going to be
able to agree on anything on
what to do about it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is the Constitution
contain protections for a
journalist who need to
misrepresent themselves while
uncovering facts that they
intend to publish, say, in a
way that contravenes a contract
that they might sign
or something like that?
FLOYD ABRAMS: Well not
to breach a contract
that they sign, no.
But generally, a journalist who
suggests to someone that
the article is going to be good
for him is not held to
that in the courts.
But there are situations in
which journalists promised
something, and then the question
is, what should the
law do about it?
One really interesting case,
occurred in Minnesota 15,
maybe 20, years ago.
Two candidates running for
lieutenant governor of Minnesota.
And one of them says to a
journalist, I know material
about my opponent which I'm
ready to tell you if you
promise me confidentiality.
Really bad stuff.
The journalist, a young
journalist, promised
confidentiality.
And he told the story of how his
opponent had been arrested
as a teenager for shoplifting
in a Woolworth's store.
Not much of a crime.
She goes back to her office,
and she tells her boss,
editor, what she's found.
The editor says, that's
no story.
The story is, he's
leaking this crap [LAUGHTER]
FLOYD ABRAMS: So that's what
we're going to publish.
And she said, but I promised
confidentiality to him.
And he said, no, no, if
the story here is--
that's just sort of
stuff he's saying.
So they published that.
The guy lost the election,
and he sued.
And he said, I had a deal, a
contract-like situation with
the reporter.
And so the question--
the issue came up to
the Supreme Court.
And the court said that it would
be constitutional, it
would not violate the First
Amendment, for Minnesota to
allow a recovery in that
case by the candidate.
The press side had argued, we
were telling the truth.
How can we be in trouble
by telling the truth?
In libel law, you always win
if you tell the truth.
And the answer was, well you
made an agreement, or at least
that's what a jury found, that
you promised confidentiality,
and you have to keep
the promise.
Yes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's
all we have time for.
FLOYD ABRAMS: Right.
Thank you all very much.
[CLAPPING]